[Laughter]
hi my name is Melissa and I'm French hi
my name is Capri Antoine and I'm
Canadian hi my name is Ellie and I'm
French
hi I'm Liliana I'm Canadian but have you
tried french snacks only they kept a
quad cutting fresh it ever did any of
Paris or French kind of snacks huh have
you ever had French snakes before I
don't think so and I'm pretty excited
because I'm gonna go to Paris in a few
days so this is like my first experience
um you know I lived in Vancouver for a
little while but I've never tried any
gimme Costner okay okay looking forward
to that I don't know I'm expecting maybe
some like a maple kind of stuff yeah
that's just like a stereotype oh it is
but we love our maple that we put in
everything so let's bring on the snacks
[Applause]
these are Curly's cacao wets these are a
little bit like funky they're kind of
like Cheetos but a little thinner so
these are really like the number one
thing in France that you'll find at
parties so this is hopkins cheesie's
same thing as her is like a party snack
you kind of have in a big bowl people
eat it out luck it through this they
definitely look thicker than regular oh
my god that smells very strong okay I
really do smell the peanut very peanutty
I thought like I don't know why because
I we're swapping so I thought this would
be like cheesy like Cheetos but
definitely not though it's not too bad
it doesn't taste as strong as it smells
which is good I can feel the cheese it's
very salty it's a tad bit crunch here
the cheese isn't as strong as I thought
okay but I like it what's up better I
think I I don't know if I like these
better than she does I think I do just
because they're bigger and I like I like
a bigger bite yeah when you first bite
it there's no real like oh my god this
one this reminds me of this as eyes you
keep chewing for a little bit longer and
then you can taste a little bit the nuts
residue in the
I think the more I eat this the more
into it is first almost like why am I
just like chewing air but the aftertaste
it smells like you know after you have
like custom mouth spoonful of like a
peanut butter yeah that's what I'm
experiencing I think I would still go
with busy Boyd I'm sorry let me have one
super by the way but I'm gonna do this
one as well I think I like yours better
yeah I like bolder flavors yeah okay
this is Joe Louie so this is like very
common in kid snacks
my Ted scene she had fortunately snacks
all the time and I'm not a chocolate
person but this one the creamy inside of
it is so deliciousness
okay these are Kenny's from Dick's might
have seen this at airports and stuff
like that because they do sell them a
lot in airports I wouldn't say they're
like a staple like you don't go to the
store and you're like oh I want that
candy but they're really really good
yeah and there's that paper layer thing
on top this is nice yeah like a little
lemon cake again very light yeah I love
how like it's so subtle it's not
overpowering and eat other things too
it's interesting because it's sweet and
I don't want to say sour but there's
like a little hint of you know Prudie
it's actually good I like it this just
tastes like a hostess cupcake or like
the yeah the hostess cupcakes but like
not as sweet and it doesn't taste this
babe for me I would still definitely go
with a French one I would pick this just
because it's just this is like this
reminds you of my childhood but it's
just like very sweet overbearing and
this is just pretty light it's so good
yeah I'm gonna go with this I shouldn't
take a little piece out that's a sure
this is lemonade Zoey nah it's just like
sparkling lemonade really nothing crazy
to it it's pretty good though
it's refreshing I would say like on a
hot summer day like this is really
really good to have Sobek Cola this is
gimmick quoi this is her kind of front
one that I'm sorry
our French version of it the main thing
is that it's made with maple syrup
oh okay so to be yeah okay that's unique
whoo I'm gonna like this
it smells like lemonade yeah but like it
smells fresh already it's not as sweet
as I thought it would be I can taste the
maple actually that's what it is I was
like cooling what does that taste and
yeah I think it's the maple syrup
[Music]
yeah very light the smell is actually
stronger than the taste itself it's so
bad okay bubbly lemonade bubbly lemonade
this is good there's a bit of a like an
aftertaste like in if you'd like diet
cokes
Oh a little nuts that taste so it's
sorry guys oh this is really good yeah
and the packaging is very nice they had
it's pretty ding ding - yeah I'm sorry
right terrified weird yeah good try good
try
this is pus these are like the cookie
especially when you're a child these are
in your lunch box this is snack time
you'll have like two of them in a little
plastic bag this is what you get when
you get out of school and what you get
whenever you're hungry because it's like
the best thing ever oh my god I'm in
love I haven't had I know friends like I
asked my parents to send me like
deodorant and creams from France me but
most of my friends French friends who
live here ask their parents to [ __ ] this
is gonna cleanse your palate from the
coke because this is maple cookies it's
really good okay I really really
recommend these like this like because
Canada you know we're known for a maple
these cooking like this like okay this
is deliciousness
it's wheel drive I would love to have
like a glass of milk right now good for
a smoke
I'm not a chocolate person but the
cooking itself is really good I do like
the cookies a bit buttery which I like
maple is all right I'm not a huge
baseball fan it is really good yeah it's
really good it's very sweet very sweet
I'm very very sweet but it is quite
delicious
back to the basics you know I'm thinking
what Canada we got one we got one
probably you guys every French people
would go back I'm sorry I Canada there's
a poser your snacks
the French snacks they were later so you
can eat a little bit more without
feeling it Parisian people are like
fancy and like their whole packaging is
like beautiful very delicate
what I didn't expect is that was very
light um so ultimately I still prefer
prefer French food French from friends
sorry because I feel like overall it's
more subtle it's more fine actually
really enjoy the Canadian snacks I knew
they would be somewhat similar to
American snacks just because we're so
close I knew there'd be some kind of
like you know what it's feel like wash
over of some sort I wouldn't buy that
you know but if they were there on a
table I would definitely eat them at a
party or something but I don't think I
would go and buy them
[Music]